In your book on cancer, you included an interview with Dr. Gonzalez on enzyme treatment of cancer. Dr. Gonzalez said that he believes most over the counter enzymes don't work for his type of cancer treatment.
How do you know that? How do you know that digest eggs, fermented enzymes and pancreatic 8x plus enzymes do work? Dr. Gonzalez also mentioned that they were involved in an NCI funded FDA approved randomized trial, clover universally, what was the outcome?
I don't know if he finished that trial before he passed away. So he passed away a number of years ago from an apparent heart attack.
There's people out there that say that he was murdered with conspiracy theory. I don't know if it's true or not.
We have all know that so many of our conspiracy theories have become realities. I don't know about that one, but Dr. Gonzalez was very much a believer in Dr. William Kelly's work.
Dr. William Kelly really wrote the book on enzymes therapy. Dr. Gonzalez kind of took up that torch and followed Dr. William Kelly's work exclusively. So his belief and at the time really of my interview with him is that he believed that the best enzymes were the pancreatic pork enzymes, which are the pancreatic 8x enzymes.
Okay, so this is the pancreatic 8x enzyme that you're talking about here really is the same thing is what Dr. Gonzalez used Patrick Gonzalez used a brand of enzymes that we also carry that's called that's from allergy research company and they are their call pancreatic pork enzymes, that's what they're called.
And they are, they're less expensive than the digestimes plus, but they're less powerful. So the digestimes plus are more powerful and that's through, I believe that wholeheartedly if Dr. Gonzalez was alive today, he would probably be using the digestives plus because the biggest struggle with using the allergy research brand.
pancreatic pork enzymes is you literally need to be taking 75 of them in the morning and 75 of them in the evening. Now that's very difficult to take that many for anybody even if you're super healthy to be swallowing that many enzymes.
And that was the compliance issue was an issue that Dr. Gonzalez, you know, spoke about quite often, there was a huge issue for helping people, the digestives plus prevented are more powerful enzymes, you could take far less.
That's the benefit pancreatic 8x is really the same thing as this. It's just a different company that makes these than the allergy research.